Gregg starts off this hour in Missouri
hey Greg welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave thanks so much for taking the
call it's a super honor to talk to you
you too sir
what's up hey thanks I am calling I've
got four kids and kid number four is a
freshman in college and we have modeled
you know avoiding debt and all those
things and she's done very very well
but if she's doing a Community College
thing right now so she's got a three two
years of college and then one of the
local nursing schools here in Kansas
City if you'll agree to work for them
for three years and possibly changing
the two years you got a nursing school
for free so she is set up for going to
college completely free however she
wants a really small little Christian
school lots of friends and she doesn't
have as many friends now in the
community college environment and
there's not tons of kids at church
because you know most of them are off to
college and so she's definitely
suffering from you know just being
lonely and wanting friends and things
like that so she is got it in her head
that she can go to Columbia some of the
Mizzou do go to their junior college and
take one class at the University and and
then you know do the dorm thing and all
that but by going to one class and then
the junior college thing but it's still
gonna cost more than nine thousand bucks
a year and so if she did it for the next
three semesters it's you know a minimum
15 $18,000 trying to convince her it's
not a good idea
and I'm kind of hoping to maybe you
could help give me something to shelter
about this evening to try to maybe put
this out of her head and I understand
completely why she wants to do it but
trying to find some wisdom on how to
convince her it's not a good idea
[Music]
where's the money coming from
well that's it she's yeah she wants to
borrow the money and you know and like
Lily you know she knows how we feel
about it but the other thing is is she
said well dad I'm gonna get a job I'm
gonna start at $48,000 I'll be able to
pay that
and and I'm like Lily and we're just
going round and round and he's trying to
to do it you know in a godly way and you
know not to beat her up and not to you
know I just want to win her heart and
get her to understand that that's just
not the way to do it yeah if it was my
daughter I guess I would just tell her I
was really sad that she felt like she'd
have spent a $15,000 of borrowed money
to get a friend well that's a good
thought - actually that's sad her social
life has degraded that far that she's
willing to spend fifteen thousand
dollars for some friends you know I
understand the whole dorm environment I
know why she wants to do it but I just
don't I mean this has nothing to do with
education yes I want to spend fifteen
thousand dollars to go to college camp
that's it you're like you want to go to
summer camp to get a friend and you want
to spend 15 grand to do it and honey I
got to tell you as your dad I love you
and I just think that's stupid I just I
really very Naya firm why you want to do
it I understand that you want social
connections I get all of that but that
that method of solving your social issue
I mean you can for $15,000 you you can
rent an apartment and just drive up
there and hang out yeah see the girl on
the weekends the visits of friends that
were like let's just keep doing that for
the next three semesters yeah yeah and
and honey I got to tell you you've grown
up in a house where we don't borrow
money and there's some other stuff we
don't do in this house you know and as
for me in my house
this is how we behave and you know that
that's not new to you and this is not
something that we're gonna endorse and
the reason we're not going to endorse it
is the same reason we don't endorse
you're doing drugs the same reason we
don't endorse you're sleeping around all
over the place is it's not good for you
yeah because I love you and I'm I'm you
know my kids when they went to school it
was like guys the way you get to go to
college free is I'm paying for it and
since I'm paying for it
it's Dave's rules and days rules are
well you know we're not sleeping around
we don't do drugs we're going to church
and we're walking a righteous clean life
we're gonna have fun I want you to have
fun once you have friends and once you
have all that we're not we're not sticks
in the mud or anything like that rims
he's like the party we're hillbillies
but but we're not gonna we're not gonna
get ourselves in trouble we're not gonna
be out getting you know ended up in the
dadgum jail drunk or something I mean
we're just not gonna do this stuff it's
not how we behave in by not doing that
that is your job and I'm gonna pay you
for that job meaning you get to go to
school free I'm paying for it and you
cease to do that I'm gonna cease to
write these checks and I'm gonna cease
to support you emotionally I'm gonna
cease to support you spiritually you're
you know because I'm doing and I'm doing
all of that for you I get nothing out of
this exactly except the satisfaction of
being a dad but I mean I get nothing out
of this otherwise yeah so I I think you
just got to sit down and talk about this
is what is good for you and what are we
really solving for here what's the real
issue and the way she's probably not got
it in her head the way you're describing
it and if she ever saw it that way she'd
realize how kind of silly it is I'm
spending $15,000 for friends yeah that's
really it and it's not going to be worth
it down the road when she's still paying
on up ten years from now it's not gonna
be worth it ever there's never a
situation in your life where you spend
$15,000 for friends at no stage of life
in no place would you do that ever at
any age you know there's not not when
you're 82 not when you're 22 not when
you're 37 with two kids there's not a
time when you spend $15,000 and
especially going in to bet for it to
have friends and to have a social life
that's a false dichotomy it's a false
set of logic and once you once you get
it laid out there and you go honey oh I
get it okay you're empathizing with it
but we're not gonna sympathize with her
we're not gonna join her in her
delusionary decision-making here
right but but but I could you know I get
your being a you know you got a soft
heart as a dad you understand your
daughter wants to have connectivity and
you know and you guys are probably in a
small town or a smaller area there and a
lot of her buddies went off but I mean I
had one that said hey all my buddies are
going to Mississippi and I said that's
great you're not well it's it's fourteen
thousand dollars more a year to go to
Mississippi from Tennessee than it is to
go to Tennessee
they're both Southeastern Conference
Schools neither one of them are playing
much football so I mean it's just it's
it's they're both good education right
and so we had this discussion I'm like
so you know who's gonna pay the other
14,000 not me and if you think you're
gonna go into debt and borrow it then
that means you're not gonna get any of
the other money cuz I'm not gonna
participate and you're crazy cuz you're
crazy is gonna bring pain to your future
life your decision-making skills are
wrong you don't go to a college chasing
a boy you don't go to a college chasing
a friend you don't go to a college
because your buddies in high school are
going there you go to a college to get
an education not to have the college
experience the college experience is a
byproduct of being on the campus but you
don't pay fifteen thousand dollars for
friends it's a good discussion thanks
for calling in